[Music]
you're looking at Houston this morning
where last night a four-year-old girl
was hit by a baseball at an Astros game
she was sitting close to the field
outside of the area where there is
protection and the accident left the
entire ballpark silent he was me in
Baltimore moments after this foul ball
Chicago Cubs batter Albert almora jr.
knew exactly what happened as soon as I
hit it the first person I locked eyes on
was her almora ripped a line drive into
the stands during Wednesday night's Cubs
after his game in Houston the ball hit a
four-year-old girl looking up in horror
a shaken Almora fell to his knees and
began crying his teammate and manager
came over to console him just praying
and I'm speechless I'm and I'm not lost
of words being a father to boys in this
photo you can see the young girl in
tears but alert being held by a man
believed to be her father she was
immediately taken to the hospital
fans were visibly distraught one woman
covering her mouth in shock after
several minutes Almora returned to bat I
had to try to keep my composure turn
that up back but one that half any was
older and I just couldn't hold it
anymore
the Cubs outfielder went over to the
stands to check on the girl and broke
down again crying in the arms of a
security guard he said he wants to reach
out to the girl when she feels well
enough God willing I'll be able to have
a relationship with this little girl for
the rest of my life
although just prayers right now and
that's all I really took control this is
tragic situation though we should point
out at the top we don't know the status
of the girl role early reports suggest
she is gonna be okay and give you an
idea of the velocity of that baseball
it's estimated it was moving at more
than 90 miles an hour well just the fact
that you could see her crying as painful
as that is was a good sign that she was
able to do that and the thing that
strikes me about the story is how deeply
he felt about what had happened the fact
that the security guard is comforting
him yeah you feel for him obviously you
didn't mean that and frankly every time
I watch foul balls in baseball games I I
wonder why this doesn't happen more
often because they go at such at such
incredible speeds those balls yeah it's
gonna reopen the debate over how far
that netting should extend should go
yeah let's hope the little girls okay
and and him too
yeah I can